hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute vor genau einem halben jahr
startete russland seien angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine und die ukraine die
würde heute auch eigentlich gerne einen
besonderen tag feiern nämlich den
unabhängigkeitstag denn heute vor 31
jahren erklärte die ukraine ihre
unabhängigkeit von der sowjetunion und
jetzt so viele jahre später verteidigt
sie ihre freiheit ihre unabhängigkeit
ihren frieden denn der krieg ist immer
noch nicht vorbei ein halbes jahr später
und immer wieder bittet die ukraine auch
um hilfe aus dem westen vor allem um
waffen diese diskussion die führen wir
bereits schon seit einigen monaten
und wie viel deutschland liefern sollte
deutschland liefern könnte darüber wird
immer wieder heftig diskutiert und auch
ganz aktuell mal wieder und ob
deutschland mehr waffen an die ukraine
für die ukraine liefern sollte auch wenn
das zu lasten der bundeswehr geben
könnte das ist heute unser thema wir
haben dazu zwei gäste gleich bei uns im
gespräch wir können sie jetzt schon mal
kurz sehen das ist zum einen alexander
müller von der fdp er sagt deutschland
muss dringend noch mehr waffen an die
ukraine liefern auch wenn das lücken bei
der bundeswehr verursacht und dafür dann
mehr waffen produziert werden müssen
dazu später mehr und außerdem auch bei
uns ralf stegner von der spd er sagt ein
rüstungswettlauf den darf es auf keinen
fall geben es braucht in erster linie
nicht warten sondern diplomatisch
diplomatische initiativen und mit ihnen
beiden da freue ich mich drauf können
wir gleich sprechen aber zuerst jetzt am
anfang unserer sendung wollen wir
aktuell in die ukraine schauen denn wie
diese lage an dem unabhängigkeitstag
heute aussieht sechs monate nach dem
krieg das berichtet für uns hannah
hebestreit
in kiel fällt die traditionelle parade
zum ukrainischen unabhängigkeitstag aus
das kriegsgerät wird gebraucht und so
präsentieren sie stattdessen erbeutete
russische panzer die wollte präsident
putin hier gern auf eine siegesfeier
rollen lassen nach drei tagen krieg doch
auch nur sechs monaten ist er davon weit
entfernt
nun haben wir ukraine beschlossen den
russen zu helfen damit ihr traum in
erfüllung geht allerdings sind die
panzer ausgebrannt oder von unseren
streit kräften auf andere weise zerstört
worden auch in diesem krieg geht es um
die macht der bilder sollen auch den
menschen die seit monaten eher lang
verteidigen gut machen ich hatte hier
fünf kameraden in meinem alter heute
sind noch zwei am leben ich kann das gar
nicht glauben ich kann nicht beschreiben
wie es mir damit geht
und so gedenken sie heute auch der nach
regierungsangaben 9000 ukrainischen
soldaten die im kampf gegen solche
waffen gefallen sind wurde er weiter
bestehenden gefahr einer atomaren
katastrophe in der ukraine hat präsident
sie lenski am abend vor dem un
sicherheitsrat gewandt
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
muss so schnell wie möglich die ständige
kontrolle des atomkraftwerks borussia
übernehmen russland muss sich
zurückziehen und mit der nuklearen
erpressung aufhören
es ist ein stiller unabhängigkeitstag
mit großer bedeutung für die ukraine
hannah hebestreit ist für uns live in
der ukraine und in deinem beitrag haben
wir gerade gehört es ist ein stiller
unabhängigkeitstag berichte uns auch
jetzt gerade aktuell wie ist die
situation ist alles bislang so soweit
ruhig geblieben
na ja wo ich habe mir das akustisch
nimmt nicht es gab hier mittlerweile
acht oder sogar neunmal luftalarm das
kennen wir das in diesem auf- und
abschwellenden töne das macht ganz schön
krass und da setzt auch uns immer wieder
einen schrecken bislang ist hier in kiew
jedenfalls nichts passiert das gilt
jetzt nicht für alle landesteile es gibt
berichte dass in anderen regionen
tatsächlich raketen eingeschlagen sind
die aber wohl im wesentlichen
strategische ziele oder infrastruktur
objekte getroffen haben wohl vor allem
im bereich der eisenbahn auch ob es da
verletzte gegeben hatte haben wir keine
informationen jetzt vorliegen ich will
nicht ausschließen dass da was war hier
in kiew wie gesagt war es ein stiller
tag die leute wurden aufgerufen nicht
auf die straßen zu gehen und sich nicht
gross zu versammeln eben aus angst vor
angriffen aus russland
und in seiner ansprache heute
präsidentin sg folgendes gesagt also er
betrachtet den krieg erst für beendet
wenn sein land gesiegt habe stellt sich
die ukraine dann im zweifel darauf ein
dass das ganze eben vielleicht noch ein
halbes jahr oder noch länger also in
jedem fall sehr sehr lange dauern könnte
sogar den ganzen um fragen die wir hier
gemacht haben hat niemand gesagt dass
das ganze in ein paar wochen vorbei ist
man richtet sich darauf ein dass es ein
harter winter würden werden wird und das
ziel was er heute formuliert hat nämlich
nicht den frieden sondern den sieg zu
erreichen das ist etwas was wir auch
immer wieder bei unseren umfragen hier
gehört haben viele leute sagen zwischen
wir haben 9.000 gefallene soldaten das
sind opfer die die die nation erbracht
hat und da kann man nicht einfach sagen
wir hören jetzt auf wenn sie lenz geht
das fordern würde wäre das so etwas wie
politischer selbstmord und vor diesem
hintergrund wird das hier sicherlich
noch eine ganze weile weitergehen ist
sei denn der druck der internationalen
gemeinschaft bringt die beiden
streithähne nennen wir sie mal an einen
tisch
danke für die einschätzungen live aus
kiew heute hannah hebestreit und
über diese diskussion ich hab es am
anfang der sendung auch schon
angesprochen also um waffenlieferungen
darum soll es jetzt gehen in diesem teil
der sendung ihr könnt dazu fragen
stellen natürlich direkt in den stream
oder ihr schreibt sie per mail oder
meldet euch auch mit kommentaren
natürlich jederzeit mailadresse jetzt
für euch eingeblendet denn lange wurde
in deutschland diskutiert liefern wir
waffen ja oder nein liefern wir schwere
waffen ja oder nein und diese
chronologie dieser entscheidung aber
auch die chronologie des krieges und
eben unserer deutschen reaktion die hat
jetzt ralph goldmann für uns
zusammengefasst
es ist der 24 februar
2022 nach dem sich russische truppen
monatelang an der grenze zur ukraine
gesammelt hatten gibt wladimir putin den
befehl zum einmarsch zu land zu wasser
und in der luft über kiew heulen die
sirenen
ukraine ist präsident sie lenski
reagiert wir geben bereits waffen aus um
das land zu verteidigen an jeden der
unsere souveränität verteidigen will die
zukunft der ukraine hängt von jedem
einzelnen ab
drei tage später verkündet kanzler
scholz im bundestag deutschland wird
waffen an die ukraine aus den beständen
der bundeswehr liefern
[Applaus]
am selben tag versetzt wladimir putin
die nuklearen abschreckung waffen der
atommacht in alarmbereitschaft
vierter märz der beschuss von europas
größtem atomkraftwerk nasa borussia
führt ängste vor einer nuklearen
katastrophe
am 24 märz beschließt die nato eine
massive aufrüstung und aktiviert die
abwehr chemischer biologischer und
atomarer bedrohungen
am 28 april gibt der bundestag grünes
licht für die lieferung schwerer waffen
nur afd und linke stimmen dagegen die
grünen sind dafür
wir zweifeln
ja und wir haben
aber und wir entscheiden und das ist am
ende das was zählt am 18 neu beantragen
schweden und finnland offiziell die
nato-mitgliedschaft zwei tage später
kündigt deutschland für juli die
lieferung von 15 flugzeugen
gebhart in die ukraine an
fast drei monate nach kriegsbeginn
meldete russlands armee man habe die
hafenstadt mario pohl komplett unter
kontrolle
und knapp vier monate nach kriegsbeginn
sind die ersten panzerhaubitzen 2000 aus
deutschland in der ukraine eingetroffen
sechsundzwanzigster juli deutschland
unterstützt die ukraine mit weiteren
waffen ministerin lambrecht twittert die
zugesagten mehrfach raketenwerfer vom
typ mars 2 und weitere drei
panzerhaubitzen 2000 sind geliefert wir
halten wort am 9 august erschütternd
explosionen eine russische
luftwaffenbasis auf der 2014
annektierten halbinsel krim und
schließlich am 23 august bundeskanzlers
scholz sagt der ukraine in kanada
weitere finanzielle unterstützung und
weitere waffenlieferungen zu
so und jetzt bei mir spd-außenpolitiker
ralf stegner und der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der fdp
alexander müller schönen guten abend an
sie beide
das kam zeitgleich herr müller sie haben
und deswegen wollen wir auch sprechen es
gibt erneut eine diskussion denn sie
haben ein das bald beitrag für den
spiegel verfasst den haben sie nicht
alleine verfasst sondern gemeinsam mit
einer mit einem spd kollegen mit
christian klink und mit sara nanni von
den grünen und in diesem gastbeitrag da
fordern sie noch mehr waffen für die
ukraine auch wenn das unsere bundeswehr
schwächen sollte außerdem sagen sie dort
einen langfristigen plan für die
dauerhafte versorgung der ukraine mit
waffensystemen dass es ihre forderung
das fordern sie anstatt immer nur auf
aktuelle herausforderungen zu reagieren
wie haben sie sich das ganz genau
vorgestellt
ja es geht dabei nicht um eine
schwächung der bundeswehr premiere
sondern es geht darum um die überlegung
wie können wir solidarität zeigen mit
der ukraine wie können wir noch besser
helfen noch stärker helfen die
bundeswehr hat selber relativ wenig
material weil in den letzten jahren sehr
stark gespart wurde bei der bundeswehr
also haben wir die köpfe
zusammengesteckt und haben überlegt was
können wir tun um der ukraine noch
besser zu helfen und dabei kam die idee
aus dass wir gesagt haben wir sprechen
mit unseren partnern also in unserem
verteidigungsbündnisses nato eu und
besprechen gemeinsam das wir
vorübergehend eventuell einige
fähigkeiten aufgeben der bundeswehr
material herausgeben was eigentlich
gebraucht wird aber gleichzeitig mit der
industrie einen plan entwickeln wie wir
schnell wieder auffüllen können das wäre
eine lösung die wir sofort der ukraine
helfen können dann die ukraine braucht
jetzt hilfe schnell wieder auf heißt
mehr rüstungsgüter
herstellen herr stegner sie haben sich
sehr kritisch dazu geäußert wie
reagieren sie auf eine solche forderung
insgesamt haben wir jetzt abgeschlossen
ich habe dann mit gestimmt dass wir die
ukraine politisch ökonomischen manager
und auch mediziner stützen ich habe mit
dem aufsatz denn der kollege müller
zusammen mit seinem team von vorne an
den geschrieben hat gleich drei
schwierigkeiten die erste ist da wird
unterstellt dass der krieg noch sehr
lange dauern wird ist er doch auch so
formuliert zweitens dass deutschland
eine führungsrolle übernehmen sollte
voran gehen sollen
eine größere rolle für die
rüstungsindustrie in alle drei punkte
finde ich problematisch
[Musik]
das ziel muss sein dass der krieg nicht
mehr so lange dauert die
staatengemeinschaft versuchen und dann
nimmt das die länder an den
verhandlungstisch zurückkehren das ist
mit dem getreide abkommen ja auch mit
hilfe der un und der türkei gelungen
sein großer schritt nach vorne
zweitens glaube ich ist es falsch dass
deutschland seine führungsrolle media
übernimmt wir sollten dabei bleiben
keine alleingänge zusammen im team mit
anderen zu handeln damit ganze zeit
gemacht immer abgesprochen was wir tun
und diese rolle für die
rüstungsindustrie finde ich auf falsche
rüstungsindustrie
würde wenn das manchen geht ja selbst
entscheiden was da geschieht das kann
nicht der fall sein unter wert kosten
können wir uns insgesamt überhaupt nicht
erlauben ich habe ganz andere
herausforderung zu lösen als diese also
hilfe jahr arbeitet die verengung die
militärische frage immer mehr zum
beispiel waffen die den krieg verlängern
aber am ende nichts entscheiden dass die
ich sehr skeptisch ich glaube nicht dass
das sein kann da scheint ja wieder eine
große uneinigkeit dann zu herrschen denn
jetzt ja auch in ihrem team mit dem sie
sich das überlegt hatten herr müller da
war ja beispielsweise auch eine spd ein
spd politiker also aus der partei von
herrn stegner wenn sich alle wieder
jetzt so uneins sind wie die frage an
sie beide wie soll man da überhaupt
weiter kommen können das ist ja jetzt
keine befriedigende situation
wir sind uns ja nicht uneinig
wir sind uns in vielen dingen einigen
der bundestag hat ja wie sie es eben
berichtet haben am 28.04 beschlossen
dass wir
mehr waffen liefern und das machen wir
auch deutschland hat sicher viele waffen
geliefert in diesem jahr es geht jetzt
darum diesen prozess zu verstetigen und
das wohl beste stecker und ich als
diskutieren ist einfach die einschätzung
wie lange dauert der krieg ralf stegner
ist der meinung der krieg ist es bald
vorbei ich sage und hannah hebestreit
hat das ja eben in seinem bericht auch
gesagt dieser krieg wird leider noch
lange dauern danach sieht es aus es gibt
überhaupt keine diplomatischen
bemühungen im moment zwischen der
ukrainischen und der russischen
regierung diesen krieg zu beenden weil
stehen sagte ja man muss das
diplomatisch lösen das problem ist dass
putin nicht ans telefon geht ja also es
ist einfach realitätsfremd zu glauben
dass das in nächster zeit vorbei sein
kann das sind nur außen generell
unterstützt die bundesregierung die
ukraine die frage ist halt wie stark
soll man unterstützen und das
diskutieren wir herr stegner
realitätsfremde nennt herr müller die
einschätzung dass das nicht mehr so
lange dauern würde was antworten sie
darauf ich weiß nicht wie lange es
dauert ich kann nur sagen jetzt was
internationale bemühungen geben das ist
noch nicht so lange daran erinnern
wollen dass jeder tag krieg bedeutet tod
zerstörung vertreibung traumatisierung
vergewaltigung und all dieses es gibt
keine kriege die ich nur gegen
militärische ziele rechnen ist ein
grausamer krieg und auch noch mit
kriegsverbrechen der pudding geld ein
fass tribunal in den haag aber dieses
lage ist wie sie es muss ja nicht was
auch nicht wie bananen oder iraks ist
die zweitgrößte der welt wir haben
gerade gehört was man schafft es aber
wichtig ist eine große gefahr also jeder
tag mehr krieg ist ein rechtliches
problem das nicht wir beiden auszuhalten
haben müller ich sondern die menschen
dort und die verteidigen sich tapfer das
dagegen kann man ja überhaupt nichts
sagen ich glaube nur dass die unterzahl
staatengemeinschaft wie sie das war ein
geteilter raum auch gemacht hat druck
auszuüben muss dass es zu spiels
gesprächen kommt weil alles ist besser
als krieg und das ist möglich halte es
nicht für naiv ich weiß nicht wie es
ausgeht aber die bemühungen ist in
dieser richtung gar nicht mal darauf
aufmerksam machen dass das was er im
deutschen bundestag beschlossen haben
und jetzt bitte ja da einstimmig für
gestimmt auch den satz enthält dass wir
auch mit schweren waffen unterstützen
aber im kern ist da von politischer
humanitärer ökonomischer diplomatischer
hilfe die rede
und das muss auch die priorität sein
dass wir helfen der ukraine sich zu
verteidigen ist das eine aber darauf zu
besetzen ist der krieg gewinnbare
militär die ukraine dass ständig eine
sehr schwierige sache wenn wir
ausschließen dass die nato sich
beteiligen das müssen wir aus schwitzen
denn sonst haben wir weltkriegs gefahren
das kann ja niemand wollen also das team
osten der ukraine zu helfen dass sie
nicht den krieg verliert aber das team
muss auch sein zu verhindern dass er
klickt sich ausweitet und insgesamt
diese humanitäre katastrophe die wir
schon erlebt haben ein ende finde das
ist meine position
auch als vertreter einer partei die
nicht eine pazifistische partei ist aber
die schon weiß was nicht schlimmer als
krieg wissen dass wir uns anstrengen
müssen dass es wieder zu
friedensverhandlungen habt lassen sie
uns noch mal ganz konkret auf die
diskussion um waffenlieferungen und was
da möglich wäre möglich ist schon
passiert schauen wir haben einen
überblick vorbereitet über das was
deutschland bereits geliefert hat und
über das was auch noch geplant ist ein
beitrag von anne stein und lena sünder
bruch
seit kriegsbeginn hat deutschland an die
ukraine verschiedenste waffen geliefert
darunter auch schwere waffensysteme die
zehn panzerhaubitzen und
15 gepard flugabwehr panzer
diese panzerhaubitze war vor vier tagen
an der front in der nacht im einsatz
die panzerhaubitze ist das modernste
artilleriegeschütz der bundeswehr die
feier präzisionsmunition bis zu 40
kilometer weit und kann deswegen auch
hinter der front eingesetzt werden der
gepa panzer ist dazu darf feindliche
luftangriffe abzuwehren neben diesen
schweren waffensystemen wurden bis heute
auch folgende militärische geräte
geliefert drei mehrfach raketenwerfer
maß
200.000 handgranaten knapp 15.000 tanzer
abwehr minen sowie luftabwehr raketen
und panzerfäusten
weitere lieferungen sind laut
bundesregierung geplant darunter zwölf
bergepanzer
215 g panzer das luftverteidigungssystem
iris t das atelier ortungs radar cobra
und 16 brücken lege panzer bieber
besonders im fokus weil die noch zu
liefernden waffen ist das
luftverteidigungssystem iris t denn
damit kann sich die ukraine noch
effektiver gegen angriffe aus der luft
verteidigen
insgesamt hat bundeskanzler scholz
angekündigt weitere waffen im wert von
mehr als 500 millionen euro zu liefern
neben den luftverteidigungssysteme
sollen darunter auch 20 raketenwerfer
präzisionsmunition und waffen zu drohnen
abwehr sein
gleichzeitig bleibt der sogenannte
ringtausch weiter staaten wie tschechien
polen oder die slowakei liefern waffen
sowjetischer bauart an die ukraine im
gegenzug sollen sie moderne waffen aus
deutschland bekommen
herr müller trotz jetzt auch neuer zu
sagen ist das ihrer meinung nach alles
zu wenig
es ist nicht unbedingt zu wenig aber wir
müssen uns auf eine dauerhafte
unterstützung der ukraine einstellen und
wir haben langsam
kommen wir an die grenzen dessen was
machbar ist nehmen wir die
panzerhaubitze die sich in der ukraine
als sehr wichtig bewährt hat die
panzerhaubitze hat dafür gesorgt dass
die ukraine in der lage ist zum beispiel
russische munitionsdepots auf große
entfernung anzugreifen und damit zu
verhindern dass die russen weiterhin
zivilisten beschießen und gebäude
krankenhäuser
das ist dadurch stark eingeschränkt
worden das heißt unsere kanzlei haubitze
hilft tatsächlich auch der ukraine
menschliches leid zu verringern und wir
haben aber nur 10 abgegeben die
bundeswehr hat es knapp 100 stück davon
und dass das ist eben halt die
diskussion ob man nicht der ukraine die
möglichkeit gibt mehr davon zu bekommen
auch wenn wir dann vorübergehend weniger
davon in der bundeswehr haben aber dann
in ein bis zwei jahren die bundeswehr
modernisieren
mit dem geld was wir auch jetzt zur
verfügung gestellt haben aber jetzt
damit schnell der ukraine helfen können
ich möchte da jetzt auch mal die meinung
unserer community mit reinbringen da
gibt es ganz unterschiedliche meinungen
zum einen schreibt an
bei youtube okay aber auf keinen fall
die bundeswehr schwächen wir sollten
auch nur das liefern was die westlichen
länder miteinander vereinbaren mercato
schreibt es braucht jetzt
friedensverhandlungen und los angeles
sollten da eingesetzt werden wo sie am
dringendsten gebraucht werden und wenn
sie dabei helfen menschenleben zu retten
was gibt es da noch zu überlegen also
auch in der community unterschiedliche
haltungen dazu was mich jetzt
interessieren würde herr müller sie
fordern mehr waffenlieferungen auch wenn
das zu lasten der bundeswehr geht und im
verteilungs verteidigungsministerium
wiederum sieht man kaum mehr spielraum
für weitere lieferungen aus
bundeswehrbeständen wie kommen sie zu
glauben dass das gehen könnte na ja das
ist natürlich eine politische
entscheidung und wenn wir uns ehrlich
machen es gibt uns fähigkeitsprofil der
bundeswehr
das ist die definition was die
bundeswehr können sollen und können muss
wenn wir uns ehrlich machen dann ist
dieses fähigkeitsprofil in den letzten
jahren schon nur noch makulatur gewesen
weil die bundeswehr schon in weiten
bereichen nicht in der lage war dieses
fähigkeitsprofil zu erfüllen weil zum
stark gespart worden ist das fühlen wir
jetzt wieder auf die ampel hat ja
gemeinsam in diesem jahr dieses 100
milliarden paket beschlossen um die
bundeswehr wieder aufzufüllen aber das
dauert diese waffen die wir jetzt kaufen
die stehe nicht im schaufenster das
dauert ein bis zwei jahre bis wir die
bestellt haben und darum geht es dass
wir sagen okay wir wissen dass wir
lücken haben in unserer fähigkeit wir
sind bereit diese lücken noch ein
bisschen tiefer zu machen gegen das
versprechen zum einen mit den partnern
abgestimmt dass wir das dürfen und zum
anderen mit der industrie einen plan zu
entwickeln ganz schnell diese lücken
wieder aufzufüllen dann halten wir das
für vertretbar denn in der ukraine wird
auch die sicherheit europas verteidigt
dazu aber direkt noch an sie von thomas
saliger bei facebook die frage die viele
lücken sollen denn jetzt noch entstehen
bei der bundeswehr erst selbst soldat
schreibt er und er würde sich freuen
wenn er einmal wieder komplett
ausgerüstet werden würde
das ist auch unser ziel wir wollen die
bundeswehr so schnell wie es geht wieder
ausrüsten aber wir finden in was ist
denn die bedrohung deutschlands wir
wollen ja in der lage sein landes und
bündnisverteidigung in deutschland zu
schaffen wo kommt denn die bedrohung
realistisch her wenn unser land
irgendwie bedroht ist dann kommt diese
bedrohung aus dem osten es wird uns
niemand aus dem süden aus dem westen
oder von der nordsee aus angreifen
sondern wenn und g bedroht sind kommt
das aus dem osten und die ukraine kämpft
gerade diesen krank
die die verteidigen die werte europas
und ich finde das kann man deswegen auch
unterstützen und auch vorübergehend auf
einige fähigkeiten dann verzichten herr
stegner hatte bin kein hoffen experten
auf erstaunt wie viele waffen experten
das war allerdings gibt damit meine ich
jetzt nicht alle kollegen müller sondern
viele andere dies dazu heißt aber der
kern was dieses sondervermögen der
bundeswehr angeht ist dass wir dafür
sorgen dass die bundeswehr
heruntergewirtschaftet worden ist in der
lage ist eine ausrüstung zu haben dass
flugzeuge fliegen das fahrzeug gefahren
und chipsets seetauglich sind digital
vogeley diese dinge da sind und dafür
gibt es diese sondervermögen um die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung in
ordnung zu bringen das ist der punkt wo
für das anlagevermögen ist dafür
gestimmt es passiert auch hier reden wir
über die frage ob man wirklich die
lösung darin sieht immer mehr waffen
nicht fügte hinzu natürlich gibt es auch
vorschläge dass leute sagen lasst uns
doch auch westliche kampfanzug westliche
kampfflugzeuge es gibt gute gründe warum
weder die usa noch die briten noch die
italiener spanier oder wieder das bisher
gemacht haben und ich plädiere
nachhaltig dafür dass ihr dabei bleiben
dass wir das im team mit den anderen
entscheidungen und das tun was die
anderen auch machen und dass wir
versuchen der ukraine zu helfen sich zu
verteidigen aber zu glauben wir können
jetzt endlos lange wochen wieder viele
monate noch jahre ich die dinge dadurch
lösen dass wir mehr überraschungen
liefern das sehe ich nicht und man sieht
ja wie brandgefährlich ist im augenblick
schon ist wenn ich die reaktion fällt
nochmals beispiel nehmen darf ungeklärt
katastrophe ausgelöst werden könnte was
verhindert werden muss also deswegen
glaube ich diese verengung auf dem mist
der frage nicht dass wir nicht
unterstützen sollen das tun wir aber die
ist falsch und die bürger auf der straße
übrigens mit denen man spricht die
bestätigen eindruck stimmig alle daran
dass das so ist und da muss meiner
meinung haben mehr personen und nicht
nur nicht darüber wie wir die chance die
am ende das nicht entscheiden wer am
ende musste eine lösung her stegner von
einem bürger habe ich hier direkt bei
facebook eine frage live im stream
alexander krük möchte gerne von ihnen
wissen erzählt zitiert sie von vorn
verantworten davor alles ist besser als
krieg das haben sie gesagt
alles ist besser als einen
unverschuldeten angriffskrieg zu
verlieren schreibt herr krücke was sagen
sie dazu herr stegner das der putin
engagiert und es nicht zulassen dürfen
ist die ukraine
dass die großen erfolg des jungen ist ja
klar aber wenn ich sage alles ist besser
als krieg dann meine ich es sind nicht
die die werte des westens verteidigen
hier in unserem wohnzimmer übertragen
mikrofon ist hätten die bürger die das
auszuhalten haben die ehepartner
verlieren die zerstörtes land vorfällen
die traumatisierte kinder haben bewegung
gibt dann das ist die realität von jedem
kriegstag den krieg zu beenden ist
besser als alles andere das bedeutet ja
nicht 20 der russischen wünschen wir
machen den sanktionen wie wir sie noch
nie gemacht haben gewusst wir kriegen
keine westlichen technologie die haben
kein einziger klicks wieder erreicht
finnland und schweden gehen in die nato
was zur verbesserung der situation und
haben dafür wird also er hat nichts
erreicht bisher mit mit dem was er heute
putin deswegen glaube ich schon dass man
darüber reden was das andere wege geben
musste ihn dazu zwingen dass er eine
fantastische zurückkehrt am ende muss
die ukraine ist natürlich entscheidet an
diesem souveräner staat haben wir nichts
entscheiden aber dann mitzuhelfen dass
das geschieht das ist unsere aufgabe
lassen sich unsere rolle und das wir
vorangehen drei ökonomischer auch wenn
ich
das machen wir
haben das man kann es auch die ihn
hoffentlich hochzeiter verhängen und
dann werden wir das schon irgendwie
gewinnen das halte ich für falsch die
experten mit denen gespräche zu wahren
es aber nicht lassen sie uns aber noch
ein bisschen konkreter auch in einen
punkt über dem sie beide auch im vorfeld
sich uneins waren noch weiter hier
diskutieren und zwar herr müller sie
hatten gefordert ein koordiniertes
vorgehen mit partnern sowie der
rüstungsindustrie was sie damit meinen
ist ja dass wenn bundeswehrbeständen
abgegeben werden die rüstungsindustrie
hochgefahren werden muss um das
auszugleichen korrekt genau das ist
richtig so und jetzt herr stegner sie
sind der abrüstungspolitische sprecher
ihrer fraktionen sie kritisieren
dementsprechend diese forderung also
soll es ihrer meinung nach auf gar
keinen fall dazu kommen wie wie es ihre
position dazu
das ganze sei eine rede gehalten als
zeitenwende r cups am nächsten tag aus
zahlreichen wahlkreisen wo kollegen der
cdu und csu
listen was wir haben alles liefern kann
wir würden dann nicht noch den kopf
teilweise schotten sie haben auf dem hof
stehen haben meist gegen durst werden
das ist klar der gewinner übrigens in
kriegen sie ist ausschließlich
diejenigen die waffen verkauft chance
gewesen dass da niemand deswegen sage
ich wir müssen kooperieren aber zu
entscheiden hat die politik wenn ich
möchte nicht dass die rohstoffindustrie
sozusagen eine führende rolle einnehmen
zu machen dass hier eigentlich gerne
möchte direkt bestellt werden kann ich
bin da sehr skeptisch war immer der
meinung wir sollten keine waffen liefern
den kriegsgebieten diktaturen müssen
jetzt auch eine helfen tun dass
gemeinschaft mit aller aber das
gegenteil zu verwandeln und zusage
schluss habe ich die hoffnung dass die
hochgefahren werden das halte ich für
falsch es ist ein irrweg am ende kostet
menschenleben und beendet nicht den
krieg und deswegen bin ich da sehr
skeptisch aber weil sie gesagt ja wir
sehen uns nicht einig sind ist nicht nur
kondition abfragen und pflegen darf man
auch leidenschaftlich ringen darum was
der richtige weg ist
deswegen diskutieren wir hier jetzt auch
leidenschaftlich weiter zu dem thema
haben wir übrigens nachgefragt also bei
der rüstungsindustrie rheinmetall
schrieb uns zurück auf unsere anfrage
heute und zwar ob sie dazu in der lage
wäre neben theoretisch da mehr zu
produzieren sie schrieben also in
deutschland sind wir dazu in der lage
unsere kapazitäten zu erhöhen und haben
dies in einzelnen bereichen auch schon
getan bei bestimmten projekten sind wir
auch ohne bislang erfolgte beauftragung
bereits in vorleistung getreten um
zeitliche abläufe zu beschleunigen
wir haben auch einen militärexperten
einen sehr bekannten christian mölling
gefragt der weiß auch zu berichten dass
das aber alles nicht so einfach sein
wird und wir hören mal ganz kurz in
seinen ton dazu gemeinsam
sicherlich muss die bundeswehr noch
einiges an material behalten um selber
den ausbildungsbetrieb sicherstellen zu
können aber wir sehen dass andere länder
sehr wohl bereit sind einschnitte in
ihre eigenen militärischen fähigkeiten
hinzunehmen weil sie sagen dass es jetzt
der richtige beitrag zur europäischen
sicherheit das heißt also die panzer die
wir haben nutzen der in der ukraine mehr
als wenn sich jetzt zu hause rum stehen
und das ist eine politische einschätzung
ich glaube dass wir in deutschland dazu
zeigen dass der risikoavers sind und es
geht ja auch nicht nur um das was bei
der bundeswehr steht sondern es geht
auch anders das industrie beständen zur
zeit als fahrzeuge noch vorhandenes war
schon seit märz angeboten ist aber ich
glaube es geht in deutschland gerade in
der debatte nicht um die frage was
machen liefern könnte sondern um die
sorge wie weit das ganze politisches
risiko darstellt die rüstungsindustrie
kann sicherlich über längere zeit ihre
kapazitäten steigern da gibt es zwei
probleme das erste ist die müssen quasi
ganz praktisch produktionsanlagen bauen
und sie müssen das viel größere problem
sie müssen auch kompetente mitarbeiter
und mitarbeiterinnen haben die die
produkte herstellen und sie müssen wir
funktionieren die lieferkette haben
alles das es in den letzten jahren
zusammengebrochen weil eben die
bundeswehr nicht mehr bestellt hat und
auch andere kunden nicht zugelassen
worden sind soll das im grunde um die
produkte theoretisch noch existieren
jetzt aber erstmal die gesamte
lieferkette wieder hergestellt werden
muss
ganz so einfach ist es also nicht
hermeling spricht außerdem von einem
politischen risiko dass es natürlich
dann durchaus geben könnte sehen sie das
nicht herr müller
natürlich ein risiko haben sie immer
aber sie müssen natürlich auch sehen
wie groß ist das risiko dass uns was
passiert wenn wir unsere fähigkeiten
vorübergehend ein bisschen
runterschrauben wir wissen ja dass die
dass russland im moment mehr als drei
viertel seiner militärischen power in
der ukraine engagiert hat im moment dh
russland hätte gar nicht die möglichkeit
irgendeiner weiteren krieg irgendwo noch
neben der ukraine anzuzetteln und die
ukraine verteidigen sich natürlich kann
man hingehen und kann sagen wir lassen
alles was die bundeswehr hat es bei der
bundeswehr riskieren das ist dann das
andere risiko riskieren dass putin
gewinnt und die ukraine erobert und das
habe ich gemacht im april mai juni haben
wir das doppel sehen wie putin sich
meter für meter vorgearbeitet hat er kam
erst dann wieder zum stehen als die
ukraine artillerie systeme von uns
bekommen hat das habe die die
waffenstillstandslinie wieder
festgezurrt ja und natürlich können wir
sagen wir lassen alles in deutschland
und liefern dann in zukunft nichts mehr
dann soll putin halt gewinnen aber der
denn dass wir das dann europa sicherer
wird und wer kauft denn dass putin mit
der ukraine zufrieden ist der wird dann
moldawien angreifen der wird dann weiter
nach westen vorrücken deswegen halte ich
das risiko wenn wir vorübergehend bei
der bundeswehr reduzieren viel kleiner
als wenn wir die ukraine untergehen
lassen dann gibt es eine anmerkung und
auch frage direkt an sie herr müller von
klem lorenz bei youtube der schreibt
wenn noch mehr waffen an die ukraine
geliefert werden sollen aus
bundeswehrbeständen wie sollen dann die
verpflichtung im ringtausch eingehalten
werden haben sie dafür eine antwort ja
der ringtausch ist im grunde vorbei das
hat mit einigen staaten funktioniert
aber da wo wir mit masse ringtausch
machen wollten hat es gar nicht
funktioniert beispielsweise polen den
hatten dialog leopard 1 angeboten das
wollen die aber nicht weil das sind
veraltete waffensysteme kann ich auch
verstehen also mit den polen kommen wir
auf keinen grünen zweig das hat bestimmt
das ist ich kann da nicht so sehr ins
detail gehen das wird jetzt so lange
dauern es hat bedingt funktioniert beim
ringtausch aber aus meiner sicht ist der
ringtausch jetzt vorbei jetzt geht es
darum direkt an die ukraine zu liefern
naja aber der ringtausch findet ja noch
statt also gerade auch mit der slowakei
ist es ja gerade ganz aktuell die was
bringt sie dazu zu sagen der ringtausch
ist vorbei ja da reden wir über zwölf
leopard panzer in wien mit den boden
bilde die slowakei ringtausch machen die
polen haben über 200 kampfpanzer
abgegeben an die ukraine die haben die
hälfte ihres bestandes abgegeben das
heißt die polen haben das gemacht was
wir gerade vorschlagen die haben es
selber gesagt wir schränken unsere
eigene sicherheit ein weil wir wissen
die ukraine kämpft gerade unseren kampf
im grunde und hat die hälfte ihrer
kampfpanzer abgegeben ringtausch mit
slowakei ich habe es gesagt sind zwölf
panzer und mit der mit griechenland sind
wir in gesprächen über die kriegen
marder von uns und geben dafür alter bnp
ist allerdings reine aber auch da reden
wir über ständig niedriger zweistelliger
stückzahlen das ist alles nicht die die
masse die die wende im krieg bringen
könnte wenn
der jetzt noch mal herr stegner aber
auch noch mal zurückkommen zu in dem was
sie natürlich gesagt haben am besten
wäre es klar der krieg endete schneller
besser schneller natürlich besser heute
als morgen so
wenn man jetzt darauf mal schaut sie
fordern also stattdessen stadt mehr
waffenlieferungen mehr diplomatische
initiativen ich möchte dazu den
ukrainischen verteidigungsminister
resnik of zu in dieser diplomatischen
lösung mal zitieren der schließt das
nämlich zurzeit aus und sagt das ziel
von verhandlungen ist ein traum unserer
partner der wunsch seines landes sei es
sämtliche vorübergehend besetzte gebiete
in der ukraine zu befreien wie soll da
diplomatische verhandlungen ja
diplomatische einigung passieren
stattfinden wie soll das funktionieren
verstehe dass das ist sehr sehr
schwierig und
niemand braucht das ist einfach das was
mir passt auch nicht aber ich glaube es
muss das ziel in den nächsten tagen
gemeinschaft zeigen auch übrigens damit
die westlichen demokratien in der
unterstützung dabei bleiben denn wir
haben steigende energiepreise haben
inflation wir haben schwierigkeiten in
den ländern und das wird ja teilweise
schon instrumentalisiert und deswegen
glaube ich schon es muss wirklich alles
getan werden um so eine beendigung des
krieges zu kommen nochmal putin hat
keins in der kriegs ziel erreicht wollte
auch schon am anfang
noch gar keine waffen geliefert worden
sind da war nichts mit drei tagen wie
hat sich das gedacht haben nichts
dergleichen passiert weil der mann hat
seine kriegsziele nicht erreicht wird
das auch nicht tun darf nicht gewinnen
aber das umzubringen zu sagen wir
verlängern den krieg infinitum andrang
wird dass die wahl von die
pausenscheiben das glaube ich nicht wenn
jetzt ein bisschen zeit probleme ehrlich
gesagt bin
hier direkt bei einer veranstaltung in
st
weil wir ihnen zugesagt haben ja dass
unsere sendung nicht länger geht als
eine halbe stunde dass es immer dann
wenn es besonders viele spannende fragen
natürlich aus unserer community gibt
aber dann stelle ich jetzt die letzte
zum schluss denn wir müssen ja jetzt
auch zum ende kommen und zwar die frage
an sie beide wie soll es weitergehen
tatsächlich wir haben sehr
unterschiedliche standpunkte von ihnen
beiden gehört zeichnen sie doch mal ein
weg für uns weil ja es wird zum einen
gerne heftig bei dem leidenschaftlich
gestritten aber wo ist der gemeinsame
weg wie soll das funktionieren
die frage an sie beide sind sich auch
einig darin dass wir die ukraine
unterstützen sagte putin nicht
durchkommen lassen unterstützen
[Musik]
sanitär und auch mitmachen die frau bin
nicht der meinung dass das ausgeweitet
werden kann und ist das militärisch
verhängt werden darf und wie das am ende
geht kann hier niemand sagen aber wenn
die industrie weniger zustimmen sie muss
das entscheiden nicht an aber mit dazu
beitragen was er gewicht gerade werden
zusammen mit anderen was sollten wir tun
und alleingängen sollten wir nicht bei
hundert politische veränderung herr
müller wie gemeinsam einen weg finden
bei so unterschiedlichen positionen
teilweise ja wir sind uns in vielen
dingen einig also ich bin sehr dafür
dass man versucht diplomatisch einen weg
zu finden ich bin aber realist in weiß
dass putin nicht dann wenn man mit sich
reden lässt also müssen wir einen
anderen weg finden
ich bin wie ralf stegner sehe dafür dass
wir möglichst schnell zu einem frieden
kommen dass wir mit unseren partnern uns
abstimmen das ist ja auch teil unseres
passt gastbeitrag gelesen da sind wir
uns überall einig wo ich mit ralf
stegner nicht übereinstimmen ist die
theorie dass wenn man waffen liefert
dass man damit den krieg verlängert ich
brauche im gegenteil wenn wir keine
waffen liefern dann gewinnt putin und
dann geht die ukraine runter und dann
ist das nächste land dran ich glaube wir
müssen waffen liefern damit es zu einem
frieden kommt damit putin sich endlich
an den verhandlungstisch sitzt sagt
alexander müller von der fdp vielen dank
dass sie bei uns zu gast waren auch an
ralf stegner von der spd danke ihnen
gerne
und danken natürlich auch an euch für
die rege beteiligung ich habe gesehen
dass kaum noch ganz viele fragen wir
werden dieses thema hier an dieser
stelle nicht zum letzten mal besprochen
haben das kann ich euch versprechen und
dann ist auch noch mal zeit für eure
fragen bis dahin sagen wir vielen dank
wünschen euch einen schönen abend und
tschüss